We have achieved our longed-for freedom.
The political victory over communism is, however,
merely the first stage of our struggle.
The historic turnaround
that has taken place in Poland
was caused by a pursuit of the Europe
from we which were cut off,
with the outbreak of World War Two.
Our actions
are playing an important role
in further transforming Eastern Europe.
Our success
will be shared with all the nations of Europe.
It would be a real misfortune if Europe
were to be divided between
the rich West and the poor East.
Let me remind you that it was the Solidarity trade union
that launched the process sometimes called
the second Spring of the People.
We continue our efforts
despite considerable sacrifices.
The time has come for
Europe-wide solidarity in full measure.
The goal
is the real integration of Poland with Europe:
as a continent of freedom, democracy and prosperity.